it's michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry phd
cosmetic chemist and paula's choice tragic
i first got into skincare around 2009 and
back then we didn't have all the brands
we have now not to mention all the skin
care info we have now and paula begoun was
pretty much the only person talking about the
science behind skincare and busting skincare myths
paula's choice and everything
else paula has done is
actually a really big reason why
science-based skincare is such a thing now
so i was a bit senpai noticed me when paula's
choice approached me to do a sponsored video
now i know paula is very busy and probably had
nothing to do with it but we don't know for sure
so we're going to assume that paula specifically
picked me like and subscribe to paula's favorite
youtuber and no one can prove that's not true
so it turns out i've never done a video where i
just talked about my favorite paula's choice
products so that's what we're doing today
paula's choice have a lot of products i feel like
i've barely touched the range so let me know your
favorite products in the comments so i can try
out more of them this is one of the few brands
where i really think that any skin type could get
their entire skincare routine from their range
they have 11 regular cleansers and 20
moisturizers without spf that is a lot
so out of the products that i have tried which is
a fraction of everything these are my favorites
we're going to start with the 2 bha liquid if you
followed me for a while you would know that this
would be in there this is the first product from
paula's choice that i got when i first got into
skincare in 2009 it was my first i guess real
skincare product that i bought for myself after
reading tons of reviews i think paula's choice is
best known for popularizing chemical exfoliants
alpha hydroxy acids and beta-hydroxy acid are
ingredients that help your dead skin cells shed
more evenly this is something that naturally
happens but sometimes this natural process
doesn't work as well as we'd like so you need
some exfoliants to come and give it a bit of
a kick along these days it seems like every
brand has a chemical exfoliant but back then
there were about eight on the market and four of
them were from paula's choice they haven't changed
this formula that much but it somehow still
really stood its own after more than a decade
paula's choice is just still really dominating
when it comes to salicylic acid formulas
this is still the best formula i've tried and
it's the one that i keep going back to this
is the skincare product that i've had the longest
relationship with i try a lot of skincare products
and for most product categories there'll be a few
different options that i end up really enjoying
and using regularly but for salicylic acid this
is the one that's sort of on its own level for me
and i've heard that a lot of other people
also feel the same way paula's choice has
a philosophy where they always try to include
other supporting ingredients in their products so
this is actually one of their simpler ones
it's got humectants in the base it's got a
bit of green tea as well to reduce irritation
salicylic acid is a little bit drying on the
skin and it can feel a bit tight while your skin
adjusts to it but i found that following up with
a hydrating toner or moisturizer really helps with
this i love using this for keeping my pores clear
getting rid of those little gray dots on your
nose and the pores i put this on with my fingers
and i mostly put it on my t-zone a few times a
week at night i also put it sometimes a bit on
my cheeks as well i also used to use this in the
morning before but now i kind of just try to keep
my morning routine as simple as possible this is
the liquid version which comes out very liquidy
there's also a lotion version but i've been so
happy with the liquid version that i've never
really had the urge to try the lotion a very
similar product is the clear acne body spray
this is just pretty much the same thing but in
a spray form i think they have a few different
ingredients in there as well but it is mostly that
2% salicylic acid this is really good for getting
my back the spray sprays even when you put it
upside down which is really handy i would probably
recommend not spraying your face i feel like
exfoliating your lungs is probably not a good idea
the paula's choice 10 percent niacinamide booster
this product is the product that converted me to
niacinamide niacinamide is a form of vitamin b3 it
is a really great all-around ingredient and it's
gotten really popular lately niacinamide helps
with brightening so it can reduce the appearance
of brown patches like a lot of other ingredients
but it's also been tested on red blotchiness and
yellow sallowness as well niacinamide also smooths
out skin texture and fine lines and it's one of
the very few ingredients that looks like it might
potentially be able to make pores look smaller but
i think the main reason people love niacinamide
is that it is one of the few ingredients that's
active but not very irritating at effective levels
if your skin isn't specifically sensitive to it
most of the other really evidence-backed
actives like retinoids and exfoliating acids
still tend to be a bit irritating even if your
skin's gotten used to it so niacinamide is like a
little working holiday for your skin so confession
time i wasn't cool enough to like niacinamide
before it became really popular i knew about
all the data backing up its effectiveness but
i tried a couple of products with niacinamide and
i didn't really see much of a difference so i gave
up pretty quickly but this serum is the one that
actually made a big difference on my skin and it
made me really probably try out other niacinamide
products i've seen other people say the same thing
that this one is just the one that works the best
for them so i think there is actually quite a lot
of variation with niacinamide formulas even if
they have the same percentage it could also be
the other ingredients in this so the ascorbyl
glucoside in that is a vitamin c derivative and
it's one of my favorites there are a whole bunch
of other supporting ingredients and antioxidants
in this too that also add to this soothing
effect so there's allantoin and licorice extract
paula's choice really love the antioxidants
and this has a massive list of them the texture
is really watery and light it's a water-based
formula it's very easy to incorporate into your
routine because it's so light it layers nicely
under everything else you can use them morning
or night i tend to use this every few nights if my
skin is particularly irritated then sometimes i'll
just use this and nothing else for a few nights
maybe also with a moisturizer there is also a 20%
niacinamide which a lot of people like if you
want to go up even higher with your niacinamide
next up is the 0.3% retinol and 2% bakuchiol
treatment this is one of my favorite retinol
products retinol is considered a gold standard
skincare ingredient it's a form of vitamin a
and it's an anti-aging superstar ingredient
back when i first started on retinol i made the
mistake of using a really big blob of the paula's
choice one percent retinol a few nights in a row
and that was a massive mistake one percent is
really strong i thought my skin could handle
it because i was used to using 20% chemical
exfoliants with no big issues but retinol
is a whole different game i think the really
sneaky thing about retinoid irritation is that
it only happens about a day and a half after
you've applied it with chemical exfoliants you can
usually tell right after you've applied it that
it's stinging too much and you need to get it off
but with retinoids the next night your
skin will still usually mostly be fine
so if you're a bit of a chump like me then you'll
end up using even more the next night because you
feel like oh that didn't actually do much my
skin's fine and then the morning after that
you realize you've just turned your face into
desiccated coconut so after that intense retinol
start my face was red and peeling and all of those
classic retinol irritation things for like a whole
week plus i caught a cold around the same time so
i was just blowing my nose a lot and it was just
really bad so that really taught me a valuable
lesson that's what inspired me to start tretinoin
super super slowly you can see my whole process
for that in my tutorial on starting retinoids
so the one percent is a really good product if
you want something really strong it's one of the
best sellers from paula's choice but i think i've
thoroughly demonstrated that i am not responsible
enough for that sort of power even now that my
skin's adjusted to retinoids i find that sometimes
i'll apply too much and then about 36 hours later
i have slightly peely skin and that can be really
inconvenient if i have a special event on or if
i have to film something it's really hard to get
makeup to sit nicely on top of peely skin so i
actually like slightly gentler retinol products
this point three retinol is really perfect for
me because if i'm really tired and i zone out
during my skincare routine and i apply a
little bit too much it is not a big deal
and this also has other ingredients in there apart
from just the retinol so it means that i can do
less steps which is always great for me and you
don't have to think about layering and ordering
and whether you're using too many things and
risking irritation it just cuts out a whole bunch
of variables and it makes everything just so much
more straightforward this has two percent because
in it as well bakuchiol is an ingredient that
comes from a plant and a lot of people have been
marketing it as a natural alternative to retinol
which i think isn't that great the argument is
that it also helps with reducing the appearance of
wrinkles and hyperpigmentation just like vitamin a
but it isn't a retinoid it doesn't work the same
way as vitamin a and it doesn't have anywhere
near the same level of evidence as vitamin a but
bakuchiol is still a pretty promising ingredient
and i really like the way paula's choice markets
this bakuchiol is there to supplement the retinol
it's not meant to replace it this also
has peptides and a whole bunch of skin
soothing ingredients and antioxidants in that
classic paula's choice formula this is a really
nice lightish lotion i found a gentle and
non-irritating and the base is thick enough
that it works as a moisturizer as well on my oily
skin at least i just really love this as a super
effective one-step foolproof product for when
i'm really tired which is a lot of the time now
next is paula's choice super light daily
wrinkle defense spf 30. this is a tinted
base cosmetic spf in australia but it's sold as
a proper sunscreen in the u.s and europe this
is the nicest zinc oxide product i've ever
tried i've talked before about why zinc oxide
is so annoying to use in sunscreens basically
zinc oxide doesn't absorb uv very well so you
need to put a lot of it into a product to get a
decent spf but zinc oxide is an inorganic mineral
which means it's basically like powdered
clay or ground up rock so if you have 13%
zinc oxide like in this formula that is about
1/7 or 1/8. so 1/7 or ⅛ of this is powdered clay
and the rest is a thickish oily base to try to
keep that powder spread out so it's a massive
challenge to make that feel nice on your skin and
if a sunscreen product doesn't feel nice then you
don't apply as much which means you don't get as
much sun protection because spf scales with the
amount you apply this is only spf 30 which isn't
that low i feel weird saying only spf 30 because
10 years ago spf 30 was heaps but i feel like
these days most of the products on the market go
for spf 50 or 50 plus and that's quite standard
so because of the i guess slightly lower than
the most common spf there's a bit less zinc oxide
in this than you'll usually see so most zinc oxide
products with spf 50 or 50 plus will have 20 to
25% which is a quarter of the product which is
a lot but for me with zinc oxide sunscreens i
just don't feel like it's worth the high spf to
feel that heaviness on my face i'm very much a
fan of chemical sunscreens if i want higher spf
the other big issue with zinc oxide is white cast
zinc oxide often looks white on darker skin and my
skin isn't even that dark but i still get white
cast with a lot of zinc oxide sunscreens this
one is tinted a little bit to try to hide that
white cast and it works really well on my skin
it did take a minute or two to settle and when
i first put it on i was kind of worried but yeah
this one is pretty unnoticeable on my face so far
no one's told me anything anyway maybe everyone's
just being really nice but i did take this photo
where i wiped the sunscreen off half my face and
i couldn't see the difference it's on that part
i have heard that some people with very dark skin
have issues with this but this is the zinc oxide
only product with the least compromises for me
two more products i wanted to shout out
firstly the c25 super booster this is a vitamin
c product it has ascorbic acid in a silicone base
vitamin c is an antioxidant that's really great
for brightening skin and evening out your skin
tone ascorbic acid is the form of vitamin c that
has the best evidence but it's pretty annoying
i've talked about this a whole bunch before it's
really unstable but when it's in a silicone base
like in this product it goes off a lot slower
because the silicone wraps around the vitamin c
and protects it against oxygen and light and
water this is quite strong which is why i'm
putting it in this separate section if you
don't already use a gentle ascorbic acid
i wouldn't recommend this i would recommend
using the c15 because this is going to sting
the c15 is a more standard water-based ascorbic
acid product but my skin loves vitamin c and i
take forever to finish products so this is perfect
for me i like to apply this by mixing it with a
different product first and then applying that
because i do find it a bit strong on its own
and i have this weird thing where i don't like the
feel of silicone skin care products everyone else
says that silicones are cosmetically elegant and
silky so i am in the minority here i usually mix
a little blob of this with the 2% bha liquid but
you can mix it in with any serum or moisturizer
paula's choice 10% azelaic acid booster this
is not actually allowed in australia because
azelaic acid is an over-the-counter drug here
but i really like this because it has a really
nice smooth texture azelaic acid products
are sometimes a bit paste-like in texture
but this one is really light it feels
a lot more like a regular moisturizer
they've also put licorice and salicylic
acid in here to make a product that's
really good for evening out skin
tone and texture and unclogging pores
so those are my favorite paula's choice
products links to everything are in the caption
thank you so much to paula's
choice for sponsoring this video
follow paula's favorite youtuber on everything
skincare science video should be popping up
here and here if you want to keep watching